you wrote a blog post that's really
interesting in uh september 2020 titled
coinbase is a mission focused company
like what we're talking about
so one interesting thing you said in
that blog post is
that we're not going to be distracted by
sort of activism within the company
that's not related to the mission of the
company
now that's a rare thing for a company to
state for companies here at the state
especially in this climate
um
can you
first of all describe in a little more
detail what you meant
uh did you receive blowback for this i
definitely received some blowback but
yeah i'll describe what i meant and um
if you want to talk about how it came to
that too we can talk about that but
what i meant is that um
there's a lot of companies right now
including tech companies but not
exclusively where
um
you know i think like great companies
they have an important mission they're
trying to do something really good for
the world
and
unfortunately they're getting a little
distracted from that at times because of
employee activism that is causing the
company to
basically jump into whatever the current
thing is and try to
help is like the positive interpretation
you know the negative interpretation
would be to virtue signal
and
my view is that this is actually kind of
destructive to um this is largely an
american company phenomenon by the way i
i i do worry that this is making america
less competitive um even though i think
of myself as kind of internationally
minded but i you know i i'm a u.s
citizen had a lot my whole life here so
um
when we put out this statement we had
employees that were not in the u.s who
were confused by it they were like
why did brian need to say that you're
just saying you're going to work focus
on work at work
that's what we were doing already yeah
you know and there was certain pockets
of the us certain cities all you know in
particular where we had employees that
um a very peculiar cultural
phenomenon had evolved where
um i think people really wanted the
company they worked at to be
you know uh
almost acting like the government or
something and like trying to solve the
hardest societal issues
and and how at least have an opinion on
it if not contribute to the solution on
almost everything
um
and for me
i kind of uh
you know i was it was a very
uncomfortable situation for me as a ceo
i'd never quite been in this situation
where
most the time when employees in the past
were kind of asking me questions
um they would be asking about like you
know how do we make this product better
like what do we do with this competitor
what about this regulator
and it got to a place around that time
where
most of the questions we were receiving
were i think even about things not
related to the company they were about
broader societal issues like brian
what's your stance on xyz controversial
thing
and
you know it was
i often like didn't have an opinion on
these really hard questions right and um
i didn't really i felt like it was
distracting the company people
internally were getting into fights a
lot too like disagreeing with each other
there was there was a thing where like
the social slack internally was turning
into social media almost with people
putting in flame wars
so and this culminated by the way with
um
a walkout that happened in the company
we we we received like some demands from
employees groups about various things
and there was like basically an
antagonistic thing with management and
employ and i was like we're all on the
same team here
if you want to be antagonistic let's do
it with somebody else outside the
company you know that we're trying to
improve the world on in that dimension
so
yeah eventually i was like okay the
company is not aligned on this
i just don't feel i don't like the job
as ceo frankly like if if the job is to
come in here every day and like
have to squirm in front of like these
the most difficult societal questions
um i don't think i want to do that job
so like either they're gonna have to go
or i'm gonna have to go
and i founded this company and i really
believe in the mission so they're gonna
have to go and
what i realized was that um so i
basically i made an exit package
available to anybody who wasn't on board
with this direction five percent of
employees took it i got the company
realigned towards this this mission
we're all here to do work by the way
people can they can go do anything like
political or social activism outside of
work it's totally fine like we all
everybody has stuff like that
um in their personal life but while at
work we can also disagree at work by the
way on the work you know this is not
like a no disagreement culture like we
should let's try to get the truth
um but don't bring stuff into work
that's just gonna create division make
the workplace a refuge from division
about all these crazy things and like
we're all aligned here to work on the
mission let's do that yeah that was
really really
really refreshing to hear
so this is me speaking but there's a
sense when companies take on these
issues publicly from a ceo position or
any anywhere else
that it does seem to optimize
for virtue signaling versus solving a
particular problem
because to solve a particular problem
you really have to
really put in a huge you have to hire a
huge number you basically have to create
a company within a company to take on a
particular thing right uh but if you
allow yourself to internally care
about a particular issue you're
basically pacifying some number of
employee like making sure slack doesn't
get out of hand and then you're doing
this kind of from my perspective
especially on issues that care about
fake virtue signaling basically trying
to understand what will make me look the
best what would make the company look
the best in this particular aspect and
it just seems very shallow and it's
optimizing for the wrong thing not for
the solving of the problems yeah but for
the
making yourself look like the good guy
and trying to then leverage that to say
i'm the good guy in all situations and
it's just it's it's the wrong thing and
perhaps from your perspective as a ceo
as a leader it's also creating division
unnecessary division within people like
they get yeah there's something about us
we get
extremely
argumentative about certain topics they
really bring out the emotion yeah
and i think that probably as you were
saying that emotion
is even probably okay maybe productive
when that emotion has to do with the
mission of the company like you really
care about those disagreements versus
like something that has nothing to
nothing to do with the particular with
uh
with increasing economic freedom
uh using crypto
yeah it's fascinating
but it was so refreshing because it's
rare
why do you think that's a rare so you
the city you're mentioning we could i
mean there's a bunch of cities uh but
you know san francisco
is one such city when one when that
culture
and
it's sad because san francisco is also
the bay area is also the hub
historically of some of the greatest
innovation in human history yeah so that
there's that tension how did that
culture emerge there
where like the innovation was done by
people that are very mission driven you
get a bunch of smart people together to
solve a difficult problem
they get uh maybe sometimes too much
blinders on but they try to balance that
and because it requires that focus to
solve an actual problem and yet that's
also the place where this culture
emerged it's a fascinating human
dynamic i don't know somebody will one
day tell the history of of silicon
valley
not just the innovation but the social
dynamics that occurred there anyway why
do you think that's so rare
well because people don't want to get
attacked it's like super you don't want
to get cancelled right it's super unpre
comfortable you know nobody wants to be
called a racist or whatever whatever you
know people want to say on twitter
so um get attacked
yeah yeah i definitely got attacked i
mean and i knew it i knew it would be
controversial the only reason i did it
frankly was that
um i was kind of at my wit's end i was
like
well like i said earlier like the job
the ceo job sucks like either i don't
want to do it or they have to go and i'm
going to make the company into something
that i want and
you know
i spent
i'd spent eight or nine years of my life
at that point kind of building this
thing i was like well i could go start
another company but it takes a long time
to get momentum with these things and
you know coinbase is a very rare thing
that happened in the world i feel very
passionate about it so
um yeah i'm not to go like i need to
make this the company that i want to
work at and what was really interesting
was that there was such a huge
outpouring of support
so i knew that it would be controversial
and i would get attacked and predictably
you know there was some um
some journalists and you know new york
times and all these people who kind of
like went and started writing hit pieces
on on the company after shortly
thereafter and they basically just call
people who've left the company and like
you know can get quotes on whatever they
want and then they'll write a story so
mainstream media i lost a lot of trust
in mainstream media frankly after that
and of course it's kind of become
obvious since then that um most
mainstream media is like hyper
politicized at this point it's basically
either super left or super right and
it's not really that focused on um
truth so that's that's kind of
unfortunate um because i think
journalism is actually like really
important in society so that that whole
thing got eroded
in the us luckily there's sort of new
media people like you um and a whole
bunch of people did that blog post help
that statement the the 95 people that
remained
is this still something you struggle
with because there it's also a culture
of the broader tech space
okay so that was an interesting thing
which was that so the 95 percent of
people stayed i got a huge outpouring of
support from people
who said
thank god you finally spoke up and said
something because
frankly
it was making not a very fun place to
work either
and i realized that there is
i think there was a i think is it the
seam to lab has this blog post about the
tyranny of the
the one percent or something like that
but there's basically a relatively small
group one and five percent or something
like that that is
really upset about something it's not
the majority of the company it's like
five percent there's another 15 or
something that are sympathetic to the
cause they're they're actually somewhat
suggestible they will go along with
whatever because it sounds reasonable
you know these are like real issues
they're talking about it's not not to
say that it's not real
and they'll kind of get swept up in it
but there's an 80 of the company that
basically
doesn't agree or just wants to get their
work done without all this drama
and or distraction and
they're afraid to speak up because if
they speak up they're afraid of being
again called a racist like fired you
know
ostracized amongst their peers and so
it did require um
it to get to a bad enough place for me
to finally say you know what i just i
feel like i have to do this
live through the short-term attacks of
the press which ultimately was very
freeing for me because now i don't
really care
and now i can actually just build the
company that i want to build without
like caring
about that so and then what was cool was
a lot of really great people reached out
to the coinbase too after that and were
like
i you know i'm an early engineer at
google or wherever and like
this culture has gotten kind of messed
up and like i want to work at a company
that's willing to stand for that and so
we've gotten a lot of good people come
over basically what i realized and by
the way are diversity numbers and all
that stuff like people told me when i
was drafting this post they're like
don't post this you're like people
underrepresented groups will never want
to work at this company again and i was
like i don't think that's true like i
talked to like our erg groups and
they're not telling me they care about
this stuff that much they're telling me
they just want to like be respected at
work and do good work and contribute so
my gut was telling me that that advice
was wrong and like i can tell you a year
a year after doing it like our diversity
numbers are basically either the same or
better in every category so that turned
out to be false
um
look i i hate to be like like i'm you
know polarizing on in either dimension
here like i just want to get good work
done and build good stuff with
technology so
you know um
i think companies should just have like
reasonable policies like you want to get
rid of bias in hiring you want to
attract great people from all
different backgrounds like you know we
have pledge percent we put one percent
of company equity into a foundation like
i hope we're able to do good stuff with
that that's
you know give back in some way but like
the main
the main message i guess for me is like
the core the core mission the core work
that we're doing on economic freedom and
just all of our products are that is
like the main value that we're
contributing in the world like let's
just do that more and hopefully we can
get from
89 million verified users to a billion
or whatever
and then um
i just think that's how we'll have the
biggest impact it's it's tempting though
it's so interesting how companies get
tempted to to help
yeah it's like and you step in and it's
almost like a drug and then you can't
you forget i mean like all of us in life
doesn't have to be companies you get
distracted
yeah and maintaining focus like you're
absolutely right the way for coinbase to
add value to the world is just to
maximize the mission
that it's on not not other not other
stuff and when you get wealthier more
successful this becomes more and more
tempting
to just help out in some other shallow
ways and
it's fascinating and you just kind of
brought that to light so it was very
refreshing and it shouldn't be
controversial to sort of
focus on just getting stuff done well
let me ask you i mean do you think that
this it's all these things tied together
there's like a general trend of like
more censorship you know there's like
more cancel culture um
there's uh
some of these like freedom values are
kind of you know even like freezing
people's accounts like the trucker thing
that happened and
it seems like there's a general trend of
um
more authoritarian
you know uh policies there
but do you think there are do you feel
like the tide is turning on that like
there's counter examples to it we've
seen recently yeah i i think it's uh the
last gasp of old way of doing things and
so there's desperation and so on because
to be fair it's kind of the internet
which is where is the source of a lot of
this where people have a voice is making
the power centers of the world really
nervous and so that's where that's
coming from i think and and the internet
is tricky it's weird it's full of bots
yeah it's full of like misinformation of
all kinds
yeah full of large groups with
conspiracy theories and so on uh and i
mean misinformation broadly people are
misusing the word misinformation they're
just
governments are just labeling random
things with misinformation just to
censor them
but
i just think it's just like a new
world where the internet is really
finally taking hold where there's
billions of devices and everybody has a
voice it's it's almost uh
basically governments
and powerful people
are slightly losing hold of power and
they're starting to freak out a little
bit
that's it anyway so and then once you
have young people that are coming up now
gain power i think will will rebalance
everything and and then there's yeah
like you said promising signs
um
that it's obvious that the majority of
people
want freedom and that means a lot of
things that means economic freedom that
means freedom to have a voice
freedom to move around freedom to act in
the way they you know without without
reasonable sort of
um
limitations by people that don't have
their best interests and
i i gain more hope from just regular
people that are
fighting
and like demanding
the
being able to have freedom of speech
or more specifically sort of resisting
crude overreach of government in the
acts of censorship
at least in the united states
uh and hopefully that percolates out to
the rest of the world that's struggling
on a much more basic level where people
are being put in prison for the words
they say not just banned from twitter
you